est ce que c'est un débat qui est
décisif pour les candidats et ce qu'ils
jouent quelque chose ou est ce qu'on est
plus dans de l'affichage finalement mais
ça ne fait pas forcément vogel
directoire alors c'est un débat aussi
ancien que les débats d'entre débat
politique on les dates 1960 débat
kennedy nixon et c'est vrai que c'est
toujours étudié de très près par les
cherche nous on l'a fait l'an
laboratoire et on ne trouve pas de
déplacement de voix c'est à dire qu'il
n'est non non il n'y aurait pas de
déplacement des regardons ce qui se
passe tous les débats considéré comme
gagnée par un parent candidats sont
aussi gagner électoralement donc comme
par hasard 10 les braves gens ce serait
celui qui a gagné le débat gagnerait la
aurait été de toi il ne gagnerait pas
élections mais aurait été pressenti par
les sondages avant même le débat comme
gagnant donc il ya là quelque chose
d'assez finalement d'assez claire quoi
c'est une c pas les débats qui changent
pourtant pourtant il semble qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose en 2017 pour la
première fois un débat d'entre deux
tours semble avoir déplacé des voix mais
là encore c'est quand même celui qui
était donné comme gagnant avant le débat
qui ignorent c'est un peu compliqué en
revanche bien évidemment ce débat est un
rite ce débat est un moment important
dans la vie politique française ce débat
va servir à certains pour conforter en
réalité son opinion mais ce n'est pas
rien d'avoir conforté son opinion à un
moment donné où effectivement
l'abstention serait probablement à une
des clés du débat donc ne sous-estimons
pas ces débats même si nos études
montrent qu elle ne marque heineken ne
déplace pas de voix et puis encore une
fois ce n'est pas parce que les études
ont montré jusqu'à maintenant que le
débat ne déplace pas le voit que ça va
pas être le cas la prochaine fois est ce
que justement on est dans un moment
particulier alors c'est vrai que jusqu'à
maintenant ça ne déplacerait pas les
vois ça allait conforter mais est ce que
là quand on voit le nombre des
abstentionnistes et les électeurs
mélenchonistes qui ne savent pas debout
où aller est ce que là pour le coup ça
risque de faire l'opinion est de faire
bouger les gens c'est ce que j'allais
vous dire c'est à dire que quand on dit
ça ne déplace pas de voix en effet
j'aurais très peu d'électeurs qui se
diraient à je voulais voter marine le
pen en fait je votais manuel maquereau
ou vice versa en réalité ça mobilise ou
7 démobilise un électorat or dans une
période où vous avez un fort taux
d'abstention dans une période où vous
avez des candidats qui sont dans des
scores à peu près comparable celui qui
l'emportent c'est pas celui qu'elle plus
large électorat c'est celui qui arrive
le mieux à le mobiliser on sait qu'on a
un électorat potentiellement très
abstentionnistes chez emmanuel macron
parce qu'il va voter macron plutôt à
reculons c'est notamment les lecteurs et
les filles c'est également une partie de
l'électorat de gauche c'est également
une partie des électeurs
abstentionnistes potentiellement à
droite du côté de marine le pen c'est
pareil les caractéristiques
sociologiques de son électorat un
électorat plus populaires font que cet
électorat est bien et plutôt pousser à
l'abstention soit parce qu'ils trouvent
qu'elle sait trop normalisés soient
qu'il trouve que bien peut-être elle
n'aborde pas tout à fait tel ou tel
thème qui peuvent les intéresser donc à
partir de là un débat si jamais vous le
ratez et bien ça conforte l'idée pour
les lecteurs que console ou vous n'y
arriveriez pas excepté rats ou que vous
avez un trait de personnalité qu'il ne
supporte pas et donc vous pouvez le
jeter dans l'abstention est l'objectif
de votre adversaire c'est justement de
faire ressortir ce qui peut jeter vos
électeurs dans l'abstention incompétence
et beau lisation pour marine le pen
orgueil et président des riches pour
emmanuel macron et de l'autre côté pour
vous il faut aller sortir ses électeurs
de l'abstention pour arriver à faire
monter votre jauge et faire baisser
celle de l'adversaire est ce que ça peut
changer totalement la donne cette fois
probablement pas mais il ya peut-être en
effet quelques voix non pas à déplacer
mais mobilisées
comme ça est ce que ce qui compte c'est
de montrer qu'on défend son programme
qu'on connaît ses dossiers qu'on est bon
sur le fond ou est-ce que ce qui compte
c'est finalement peut-être un peu plus
l'apparence est de trouver la bonne
formule c'est de trouver la tac qui fait
mouche face à son adversaire
d'avoir ce qui compte c'est de ne pas
tomber c'est à dire et c'est là que la
métaphore sur le match ou sur le
spectacle sur le sport et serra n'est
pas tout à fait faux c'est à dire que on
regarde aussi ces débats pour pour
jauger de la capacité des hommes
politiques dans la vie d'une manière
générale donc dans la politique moi
j'avais observé qu' il que les camps
dans un travail que j'avais fait
empiriquement des gens qu'on a des
rejets finalement il avait trois
manières de juger les hommes politiques
au moment des débats ca pour eux il est
observé pour savoir si c'était un bon
psy était bon en communication donc les
français sont des experts donc il dit il
est bon en coop ou pas hein il pense
aussi qu'il faut ce sont des comédiens
et donc ils veulent savoir si ce sont
des bons comédiens ou des mauvais
comédien et donc on trouve beaucoup il
s'est bien préparé il était à l'aise il
était enfin bon tout à la baisse et puis
il ya aussi l'idée d'authenticité c'est
à dire il pense aussi qu'à travers ces
débats il vous révéler quelque chose de
donc si vous arrivez à danser sur ces
trois éléments à gagner vous pouvez être
bon mais et quatre éléments que ne
disent pas les gens comme nous
interrogeons
c'est la question de la faillite c'est à
dire de l'échec de l'accident et là il y
a le risque d'un accident et là on
imagine bien que si emmanuel macron beau
je ne sais pas quelles raisons dino
rouges ont particulièrement désagréable
je suis parfois on sait pas où elles ont
éventuellement marine le pen mais c'est
d'aller dans un autre statut à ce moment
là il peut y avoir tout d'un coup un
déplacement moi je pense que c'est un
petit peu le choix qu'avait fait marine
le pen en 2017 si elle savait qu'elle
allait perdre les sondages étaient
claires et s'est dit lui joué mon
va-tout et elle joue son va tout au
risque de perdre je pense qu'elle sait
qu'elle risque de perdre en faisant ce
qu'elle fait mais à la trump il y a la
possibilité qui se passe quelque chose
donald trump personne de penser que d'un
autre on pouvait gagner il a gagné en
inversant les règles communication
politique et en inversant les règles
communication ils les connaissent comme
vous et moi les rêves de la
communication politique donc s'il ne les
respectent pas s'ils choisissent de ne
pas les respecter et auquel prend le
risque je vais peut-être père médecin
son jeu perd et si jamais il se passe
quelque chose pourquoi pas donc il y as
voilà c'est incidents de communication
qui peut gagner ou qui peuvent faire
perdre et c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
adore regarder ces débris justement
puisque vous parlez de ce débat de 2017
ou la fiche était identique évidemment
emmanuel macron face à man le pen on va
en revoir les temps forts avec gaspard
flamand et alexandre tout ça
c'était il ya cinq ans le 3 mai 2010 est
12h30 des changes mais surtout
d'invectivés dès les premières secondes
ces macro et le candidat de la
mondialisation sauvage de l'ubs et
risation de la précarité de la brutalité
sociale de la guerre de tous contre tous
deux du saccage économiques notamment de
nos grands groupes vous avez démontré
que vous n'êtes en tout cas pas la
candidate de l'esprit de finesse de la
volonté d'un débat démocratique
équilibré ou vers le futur président
joue la carte de la tranquillité mais ne
manquent pas d'attaqué en retour vous
êtes en train de lire une fiche qui ne
correspond pas au dossier que vous avez
cités c'est triste pour vous parce que
ça montre votre impréparation à nos
concitoyens si la sortie de l'euro n'est
plus au programme du r n aujourd'hui
elle l'était il ya cinq ans dossier sur
lequel marine le pen s'était retrouvé en
difficulté vous proposez vient de sortir
non je vais renégocier pour que l'euro
on s'en libère et on le transforme en
monnaie commune c'est ce qui lève existe
c'est ce qu'il a il était avant qu'il
devienne la monnaie de la france avec de
l'euro les choses soient très claires
non ne paiera pas de leurs adversaires
et bien les banques centrales perron ac
de l'euro si elle le souhaite mais ce
qui reste un des temps forts du débat
c'est cette réplique de marine le pen
quand ils manuel macron évoque les
militants du rnd
région je dis juste vous disiez juste
une chose regardez
là ils sont dans les campagnes dans les
vies par les deux réseaux sociaux je
parle du parti de l'extra les
envahisseurs celui que vous dirigez pour
le match retour de ce soir à 21h le
tirage au sort a désigné marine le pen
comme première intervenante mètres
anglais pour commencer le match retour
c'est pas souvent c'est là je voulais
seulement la deuxième fois sa chance
quelque chose ça sera un match retour
oui parce que malgré tout il ya une
curiosité également parce que parmi les
candidats afin entre les candidats il ya
déjà un passif et donc à partir de là il
ya la nécessité pour marine le pen de
prouver que ce débat qui n'avait pas été
très très bon en 2010 est sans lui faire
offense et bien elle peut faire mieux et
qu'à partir de là tout ce qu'elle a
gagné pendant cinq ans quand vous prenez
aujourd'hui les traits d'image de marine
le pen outre la dédiabolisation dont
parle dont on parle beaucoup il est
également une crédibilisation
aujourd'hui sur beaucoup du thème
notamment sur le pouvoir d'achat elle
apparaît aussi créé déboires sur le
pouvoir d'achat plus crédible qu
emmanuel macron il faut voir que
l'électorat est capable de pardonner un
échec 1 prenez par exemple le l'exemple
qu'on donne le mieux c'est celui de
gerhard schröder en allemagne vous avez
un chancelier qui est à bout de course
et tout d'un coup il agit bien lors
d'inondations qui sont majeurs en saxe
et ensuite il est réélu parce qu'en
réalité dès le moment où vous
transcender votre image vous êtes
capable de faire oublier à l'électorat
que vous avez pu avoir des échecs et
bien l'électorat vous pardonne et oublie
encore faut-il ne pas retomber dans les
mêmes travers et donc là elle est
forcément extrêmement attendus lors de
ce débat ensuite c'est le match retour
et c'est un match qui n'est pas tout à
fait dans les mêmes circonstances parce
que évidemment là il ya cinq ans c'était
projet contre projet da ses projets mais
ces projets contre bilan est évidemment
un président sortant a toujours beaucoup
plus de mal à se justifier de son bilan
pensez à valéry giscard d'estaing pensez
également à nicolas sarkozy le débat de
président sortant est plus difficile
tout bêtement parce que eh bien vous
donner beaucoup plus prise aux attaques
qui ne se portent pas
de vagues idées mais qui se portent pour
le coup sur quelque chose qui est devenu
clivant et c'est ça la différence
également par rapport à 2010 est marine
le pen et clivante emmanuel macron les
taux si on a un président de la
république qui a une base extrêmement
forte mais qui a une base d'opposants
également très mobilisée pour marine le
pen il faut aller la chercher et ça pour
le coup ça joue contre emmanuel macron
presse que ça veut dire qu'on se parle
c'est plutôt avantage à marine le pen
sur le fond parce qu'effectivement elle
a un bilan d' emmanuel macron attaqué
alors que lui il a un programme c'est
toujours peut-être plus à ce très
abstrait pour les français un programme
qu'un bilan et sur la forme parce qu'on
dira mais de toute façon c'est mieux
qu'en 2010 est en tout cas ça peut
difficilement être pire pour elle oui on
peut dire ça je suis pas sûr il a des
difficultés pour les deux puisque
l'allemagne ont été avec a prouvé qu'il
avait les toffes 1 ce qui est essentiel
dans les choix électoraux c'est il faut
que vous regardez ce qui est arrivé à
valérie pécresse ou anne hidalgo chacun
causé rick hallet pas les toffes de
président de la république alors que
yacine donc lui il avait a prouvé qu'il
avait des tofs maintenant il ne peut
hélas pas besoin de le prouver il a été
pendant cinq ans elle elle doit le
prouver donc ça il est dégagé de quelque
chose qui comme assez importante enfin
qui est pas un seul qui est très
important ll va être jugé à partir de
quelque chose qui a été ratée ou d'une
certaine manière il va y avoir
effectivement de l'indulgence à son
égard surtout qu'elle recommencera les
mêmes ne pas les mêmes erreurs lui elle
est là elle peut attaquer sur le bilan
attendait ne publiant n'est jamais
satisfait personne n'est jamais s'être
totalement satisfait de son niveau de
vie surtout en cinq ans personne ne peut
vraiment nous rendre celle-ci fait on
considère que chacun veut près 20 30% de
plus de son salaire pour être heureux
donc c'est clair c'est comme ça mais le
le risque c'est qu'évidemment
les traits d'image qui colle à emmanuel
macron ne soit pas enlevé par ce débat
c'est le président des riches puisqu'ils
ne veut partir il ne veut pas remettre
le l'impôt sur les sur les riches et
cédera donc comment est ce qu'elle peut
attaquer ceux là ça va ça va être
compliqué je sais pas quelle est pour
qui et pour qui ce sera le plus facile
ou plus difficile on va parler de
l'image mais juste un mot parce qu'on
dit beaucoup que ce genre de débat il se
joue dans les détails on sait tout est
tiré au sort que tu ai discuté avec les
équipes des candidats là le tirage au
sort a tiré marine le pen pour parler en
premier ce soir est ce que ça c'est
important pour moi je l'entendais
qu'elle a surtout tiré le fait de
terminer et c'est elle qui l à
l'introduction et la conclusion alors
autant l'introduction ça a été assez
important du cac pour les analystes en
2010 est parce que on a été frappé ou là
vous avez raison de frappe et qu'elle a
tout de suite cogné c'est vraiment le
mot contre emmanuel macron alors qu'on
aurait pu imaginer
logiquement c'est ce qu'on apprend à
sciences po qu'il fallait qu'elle
présente son programme ilc ensuite m
elle a choisi le cogner da donc elle a
donné le ton du débat est ce qu'il était
possible ensuite pour emmanuel macron de
réagir du fait de ventes lesquelles elle
a fixé le ton donc ça c'était important
mais je trouve quand même que le
avantage c'est la conclusion parce que
malgré tous les six la conclusion est
réussie on reste sur ses dernières
impressions donc le tirage au sort peut
être important oui deux éléments qui me
semble plus important dans ce qu'ils ont
été décidés c1 les thèmes avec un thème
qui va commencer sur le pouvoir d'achat
qui fait qu' elle commence en position
de force après avoir si les
téléspectateurs vont gars vont regarder
dès le début ou dix minutes après donc
c'est un peu le danger mais malgré tout
a priori pour ceux qui vont commencer le
débat ils vont voir une marine le pen
sur ces thèmes le deuxième élément c'est
qu'elle a obtenu la suppression des
plans de coupe or ce qui entre
guillemets la fragilise en 2017 c'est
pas tant ce qu'elle dit et quand elle le
dit c'est ce qu'elle ne dit pas quand
emmanuel macron parle ce sont ses plans
de coupe qui en réalité la montre en
difficulté notamment avec ses fiches là
il y en aura pas ça c'est important
évidemment les plans de coupe c'est une
vieille histoire le plant coup puisqu'en
se souvient qu'en 81 françois mitterrand
avait considéré qu'il avait perdu des
élections soit 114 à cause des plans de
coupe et qu'il avait demandé à ce qu'ils
soient supprimés en 80 donc le débat
évidemment été beaucoup moins
intéressant et puis avait toute une
histoire vous voyez couve de murville
qui écoutait quelqu'un en face car en se
moquant de lui moi je trouve que je
trouve assez légitime qu'on retire les
plans de coupe je veux dire autant une
femme ou un homme politique
un premier pont et tu te dis peut-être
on expliquerait ce que c'est vrai que
oui nous on connaît c'est le plan qui
est sur la personne qui ne parle pas
pendant que la personne pas voilà et
dans la réception d'un message
il faut que celui qui parle ne soit pas
bon que son propos ne soit pas brouillé
or il est facile pour celui d'enfants en
face de manipuler d'une certaine manière
ce qui se passe de l'autre côté donc je
prenais en jeu si grave dit elle après
avoir dit qu'il n'y aura pas d'enjeu
que le débat entre les deux tours il
semble légitime qu'on accorde aux
débatteurs le choix des armes et qu'ils
aient sentiment lorsqu'il parle qui ne
se passe pas quelque chose en dehors de
leurs propos qui ne peuvent pas
contrôler
[Musique]